[Musique]
lavez vous les mains en chanson ou non
mais lavez vous les mains
ce geste d'hygiène et montrer répéter
ironisé à la télé depuis des années 50
pour les petits de la maternelle chez la
séance laborieuse de lavage des mains
qui de cabinet bien sûr il ya les
campagnes officielles du ministère de la
santé comme en 2009 en pleine pandémie
de grippe h1n1 au quotidien une main
peut contenir et transmettre plusieurs
milliers de microbes mais aussi le geste
beauté en 1964 l'émission le magazine
féminin en donne tous les conseils pour
étaler jusqu au bout des doigts sachez
qu'il est un certain nombre de choses
qu'il faut éviter si vous voulez les
garder sous peu et belle l'eau trop
chaude comme l'eau trop froide par
exemple en revanche une eau tiède elle
aussi par un peu de bicarbonate et
parfois le bicarbonate parfait pour les
mains sèches un peu moins pour les
désinfecter dans les années 70 il n'y a
pas encore de solution hydro alcoolique
mais en l'absence d'eau et de savon
cette sage femme a son petit truc faune
et de l'agneau on avait les mêmes c'est
que l'hygiène des mains est une priorité
pour le corps médical
enfin pas tout à fait écouter ce
professeur en médecine en 1994 médecins
que le geste le plus important c'est le
simple lavage des mains est bien ce ce
geste essentiel est un message qui passe
assez difficile
ici on en ferme et les récalcitrants aux
toilettes par exemple voilà l'idée de
cet inventeur en 1998 avec sa trouvaille
impossible de sortir du petit coin sans
se laver les mains
la cimo passait pas
dans le robinet vous sortez pas ou plus
simple rappeler les gestes de base dès
le plus jeune âge
voilà la mission de ces étudiants
infirmiers à rennes en 1999 ils vont
dans la bouche dans la bouche après ça
peut faire des maladies l'hygiène des
mains le sujet sérieux il y a même une
technique officielle européenne en sept
étapes de 30 secondes chacune
démonstration en grand en 2011 sur un
madison à toulon pour alors le petit
geste paume contre pauvres
dessus-dessous pousse bien sûr et on
termine par les poignets après ça lui d'
excuses
[Musique]